do you ever feel weird weird sometimes I  feel like I'm always on the outside  there's this invisible line that I have  to cross to really be a part of  everything and they just can't ever  cross it me too my name's Simon I'm just  like you except I have one huge ass  secret hey I like your boots I said I  like your boots goodbye  nobody knows I'm gay sometimes I feel  like I'm stuck on a ferris wheel  [Music]  one minute I'm on top of the world  [Music]  than the next cement rock-bottom  [Music]  I've been thinking about why I haven't  come out yet maybe part of me wants to  hold on to who I've always been  just a little longer  [Music]  [Music]  no matter what announcing who you are to  the world is pretty terrifying because  what if the world doesn't like you  PS doesn't seem fair that only gay  people have to come out find straight to  default I have something I need to tell  you I like girls try to get me I like  men  I'm straight heterosexual  you